Runk
hello
hello yeah it's all good so I'll be in
Colona coming up here February 9th I
mean the most chill way to so if you
want to come out cool if not all good
welcome to Lifeline everybody it's
episode I don't even know what episode
number is is it5 95 95 the year I was
born
1995 not true episode 95
Lifeline we love doing this we love that
you're here we love being here what do
you got to say well I was going to say
join the patreon for Lifeline luxury and
you get more episodes definitely
patreon.com Lifeline luxury definitely
do but I will be in Vancouver Chrystal
Leia will be in Vancouver Rochester New
York kitner Ontario you know what I
actually added a bunch of new dates so
go check it out uh go to yeah uh Rapids
Fort Wayne Indiana Sagen never been to
that doesn't know where it is dude
Michigan yeah no I do apparently it's a
somebody was saying it's a it's a big
gay area Saga mhm which means it's nice
they're sagging off their pants and you
know doing stuff with each other's
penises that funny but uh Charleston
South Carolina Chattanooga austa I don't
know if I've been to Augusta Georgia but
anyway I'm going all there go get
tickets at chris.com they are on sale
right now and check out Matt's new
podcast private record um the privat
record.com uh I saw the second episode
is that guy's story was wild hell yeah
dude oh yeah episode three coming out
this
Wednesday uh someone's dad affair with
sisterinlaw someone's dad someone's dad
had an affair with his
daughter-in-law for years dude okay
that's the craziest that might be the
craziest that's the most soer episode
you know I me that's porn but okay
basically porn yeah uh so go check that
out and go to watch lifeline.com if you
have questions or uh you want to uh
submit and then you got the merch there
at lifeline merch.com and then also you
got this merch here at chris.com LIF
rips can I touch it yeah and 80s song
can I touch it um can I touch it can I
touch it can I touch it that's how it go
that's how it we go that's a good song
um anyway
dude I already drank a magic mine but
with magic mind you drink it all the
time at the beginning of the episode
because it gets me going but everybody
likes it Anthony drinks it likes it
Chris drinks it likes it Everyone likes
it because it's good it's a good product
D June I like it um my hair rate it we
kind of match uh that's a nine what
that's a nine for
sure that's a nine what's that from I
don't know it sounds like it's from
something though right June shaking a
lot June stop being scared of everything
dude she wakes up and it's just like oh
oh no Oh no you're you're a scary guy
dude no it's not me it's not me I woke
up
today it's okay Jun Cy was in my
bed and he said good morning oh that's
so cool yeah um and and so anyway I I
woke up and I I didn't want to get out
of bed and I did and then I drove down
here and it was and it was uh raining
and the rain sucks thought it was going
to be a long time to get here dude got
here so quickly so that's good you early
yeah and then and then I was going to I
I was like Kristen I said can I take
your car because my my car's in the shop
my Mercedes in the shop she was like no
because I have to take Calvin to school
and I was like oh yeah okay I didn't
want to drive my really nice car
downtown yeah so I'm like um maybe I'll
Uber but then the alarm went off dude
christon hit the snooze button and and
she didn't get up and I was like
Calvin's not going to school oh really
yeah so so now I got so I got her I got
her car which is basically my car too
but dude when he's older that kind of
thing is going to be like the best D
well he woke now though he's probably
like take me to school dude I want to
like yeah but but so he loves school but
he today he woke up and he thought it
was before school it was already after
school cuz she was in bed when I got up
but I mean a Christopher Nola movie what
is happening it was yeah so confusing
before school but it was after school so
when they woke up woke up it was after
when they should have woken up okay
right right and uh I'm in the shower and
Calvin comes in and just goes and then
runs and goes in peace and then um and
then uh Kristen
said um he said good morning he said
good morning and I and then I said so I
guess he's not going to school I could
take your car and she said yep and then
Kevin said I don't want to go to school
today already so it worked out for
everybody yeah everything worked out
everybody's happy she got more sleep
Kevin didn't have to go to school and I
got to drive the car that's good that
everything worked out at your house cuz
I woke up real anxious really just dude
it was one of these it was anxious you
know just roll out of bed how how many
days out of a week or like what was the
percentage you wake up anxious honestly
lately I ha I can't even believe it but
lately it's like six out of seven days
of the week yeah I had that a few like a
month ago it was every day I woke up
anxious is there anything better than a
like you don't realize it but you come
out of a period like that and then one
day you wake up and you realize you're
not anxious and you're like oh my god
when did this happen it's awesome why
did I CH how do I make sure that never
happens I try to I try to understand why
because like okay I had I was doing the
road and waking up anxious when I get
home wake up anxious I got home from
Albuquerque and then I I I I went on
stage at The Improv in
Hollywood and I had a great set it felt
so good and then I had another great set
I did two shows there and
then I then after that I didn't wake up
anxious anymore H and it was just
because like I felt so good that I was
at home I had my family and I wasn't on
the road and you know I just had a good
night performing it it also wasn't my
crowd when I went up and I was you know
I've been performing for my crowd a lot
you know but like when I'm a guest it's
it's and I do well it's more satisfying
because sure who's yeah these people
David Lucas it was his show yeah oh but
anyway it was it was awesome and and I
haven't been anxious since although it's
probably right around the corner oh yeah
it always it always is here's another
good
thing hit my head uh about three month I
would say maybe it's two months ago okay
in a in did I talk about it here I hit
my head on the um I don't know you
definitely on uh in in a sprinter van
had a shelf in it I think we did talk
mention it you told me I don't know if
it was on the show I think it was on the
show anyway we don't have to get back
into it not a big deal but uh and not
interesting but what is interesting is
every now and then since then when I
move my head like this every very now
and
then somebody shot me in the back of the
head lightning rod dude one time light
Rod sword from the top of my skull Shing
down into my through my long how long
ago was this two months ago like I said
just now I wasn't listening to that part
it's interesting so two months ago and
every very now and then I'm talking
about every five days days it's just
crazy and it never happened before yes
dude and it never happened before and
you and you get older and you experience
pain and it keeps happening and it's
never going to end and that's great dude
and it was all because I just [__] we
we pulled off to the gas station to go
pee pee and then we pulled back on and I
[__] hit my head on the Shelf in the
goddamn Sprinter van so who are you
going to blame it on because you're not
going to blame yourself I'm not no I'll
blame it on probably I think it was
Denny's fault Denny probably had to go
pee I think it was either Denny or Lulu
I can't remember who had to go pee it
might have been Sam even it wasn't even
you who had to pee no I never have to
pee dude I'll tell you what dude I never
have to pee when I'm traveling it's the
craziest thing what about normally
always okay but what is that that's
really weird yeah it is weird because
dude when I do my zoom meetings I have
like men's groups and [__] I'm I have a
zoom meeting sometimes I have therapy
for hours right I got to pee like three
times during the the the session does it
have anything to do with the fact that
you know you can't pee when you're
traveling so you think your brain does a
little bit of May maybe maybe it might I
thought about that yeah it's crazy
though I can't believe how much I pee do
you how much do you wake up at night in
the middle of the night and pee I mean
I'm peeing right now uh wow I wake up uh
I dude weirdly I used to wake up like
two or three times now either one or
zero when was that D when I wake
up the amount that I have to pee oh dude
it like in the past year it's gone it it
it batt it's like at war with my desire
to stay in bed yeah it's like it's like
it's from filled up to here with piss
exactly any slight movement it might
even come out you know cuz you got to
use a muscle you're talking about when
you're in bed when I'm waking up any if
I get out of when I'm getting out of bed
it's like I move like this to get up and
it might like a little bit might come
out cuz I oh I'm talking about Oh I
thought you talking about something else
what did you think I was saying the
amount I have to go pee now is it's like
my bladder grew like the grin's heart oh
maybe I don't know about that that's not
me yeah that ain't me that ain't me that
ain't me nah n b but dude I I can't
believe dude I'm there and I'm going I'm
like oh man I'm like oh man I got to
stop peeing I'm tired oh man dude and it
keeps going I'm like surely it's done
soon and then it's not I'm like oh dude
I just want to go back into bed I'm just
waiting and just tinkling it's crazy by
the end you're just like fully awake cuz
it took so long yeah and it's and you
know what it does pisses me off no pun
intended but nice dude but um I hate
waking up to pee and I do it it's always
like at 6:00 a.m. I I wake up and I I go
I'll go before I go to to bed and then
if I still haven't been in bed in 30
minutes I'm like let me empty it out let
me top it off you're you're on top of
emptying it out yeah dude always at 6
a.m. I wake up and I'm like every
morning I wake up and I think should I
go do it or should can I sleep again H I
think I'll be all right and then I wait
like 20 minutes I'm like got to go yeah
you always you always should go but
that's why I want to have diapers well
don't no one's stopping you I thought
you I thought you had I do I piss the
bed they go so far they go everywhere
that it's not enough so get a it's not
enough mate get a bigger diaper I need a
bag I need a colostomy bag that's not
what dude if I slept with a big big the
diaper big enough would be so big i'
would be like bah boy I mean like I need
you'd roll into bed yeah I need I need a
somebody got to make a big diaper not
for uh seniors bet I bet they do no make
a big diaper for 40-year-old but I bet
there's big diapers for great big fat
people that you can get even though
you're not a great big fat person I want
to look into it if somebody knows leave
drop a comment on Lifeline somebody
knows for sure um lot of doctors listen
to the show so let us know are they made
to put to just have like a full piss no
no the dep pens for seniors are supposed
to be just for little leaks out of the
penis well why even bother if you're
going to make I didn't know that I got
cuz I got the heavy FL not you why
bother I'm saying why bother they make
them if you're G to make a diaper let it
hold the whole the whole show I mean but
just imagine pissing like a half liter
into a [__] like what's going to hold
that evaporate it evaporate it evaporate
but that's what I'm saying so it up soak
it up soak it up soak it up evaporated
evaporated evaporated soak it up soak it
up soak it up Matt okay um all right so
I was going to tell a great old story
about hitting my own head but you know
what we should start let do we'll do
Lifeline luxury all right cool so um
sign up for that
uh.com is a wild head head hitter story
yeah it's actually utterly hilarious but
yeah oh okay to Horn totin what's up
Matt what's up Chris need some advice or
an
opinion um me and my wife have three
boys we don't really want more children
uh we don't want her taking birth
control cuz that turns her into a
psychopath so I'm thinking about getting
a vasectomy mhm what's your thoughts on
it I'm like 90% sure I want to do it the
other 10% of me
thinks no don't do it you're a man you
need
to make breed reproduce for as long as
you can but that's the animal part of my
brain I don't really know what's your
thoughts on it got the appointment
scheduled
oh the operation seems really awkward
but that could turn into a funny story
later if you want to update so yeah get
a vasectomy how do you feel about it let
me know get a aomy so you can tell us
how it went no uh I mean I think do it
you can't you reverse them nowadays can
you yeah definitely do it it's also from
what I understand
extremely extremely not invasive for
what it sounds like yeah I I I couldn't
do it for the reasons he's saying or you
just don't like the I just don't like
the idea of I get that it's just weird
to me and and I I don't mean it's weird
if you do it I mean for me I would feel
weird I get that like I I I just I can't
wrap my head around it for some reason
it might be stupid but I just like man
yeah I mean it is a really really really
common extremely lowrisk thing yeah well
it's not about the risk it's not oh no
it's about H but that's my stuff that's
you know what I feel like that about at
least surgery like everything for every
reason I should get it but I'm like
those are my eyes well for lasic for me
it it the risk is the thing that scares
me that's it is there much risk involved
still yeah it's not even the risk it's
like I mean I guess it technically is
but yeah it's just a weird thing about
my eyes no uh my my balls thing is not a
risk thing it's uh it's uh but that's
part of me and that's weird it it's in a
way it's like when I didn't want to
start taking medication because of my
OCD I was like yeah but I well that's
kind kind of what he's saying he needs
himself to be intact in this way because
that's how but it's not a mate mating
thing sure it's not a you know I don't
think it's a biological thing for me in
my head yeah um but yeah if you know you
don't want kids and your wife isn't
going to go not I mean I I agree she
shouldn't if it if it really messes with
her her mind and and brain and the way
she feels definitely don't you know
obviously she shouldn't be this seems
like a simple solution cuz again you can
undo it and plus you already have three
kids yeah you know you don't want kids
you know you want to be with your wife
you love you have a great situation
obviously you want to keep going you
know what I'm saying so like I mean the
imagery that's up on they cut the tube
like that yeah I could never no way
let's see wait leave it out the glands
okay so the glands of the penis is going
like this the scrot under that does it
is it cuz my penis is much bigger than
that so does it like it hangs way way
way below my ball this I don't get this
this is like this doesn't apply to me
this is way this is more like yours no
this is way too small if you have to
this is I don't even understand that
okay so hold on
uh what they saying oh the vast they
actually cut the cord I oh the vast
difference is divided no that's not the
vast difference okay so all right so
that's too that's too much yeah but uh
so so easy dude if you're going to do it
do it uh and and and you should but uh
yeah not for me I I it makes me feel
weird even thinking about it honestly
this is a horrible horrible graphic this
is so unclear it's exactly how it you be
wait never mind I see it now they cut it
they literally it's exactly what part do
they cut where am I looking to see what
the the a close in circle uh what do you
mean do no there's a glare right there
I oh they put the lights in Chris put
the lights in the wrong spot yeah he did
he put the lights in the wrong spot so
okay um all right so uh yeah that's so
easy dude get her get her done hey say
get her done I I I talked to somebody
who had a
um uh vasectomy and and he was like I
did it so I can have sex with my wife
and not worry about it and mhm
um and it's just e e and and I was like
oh that's crazy he's like but I just
love he he legitimately was like I love
having an orgasm like inside my wife so
I was like okay wow well well that is as
direct of a good reason as you could
possibly get so good for him I just
realized what why it's called a
vasectomy because they're cutting the
vast difference
thing the vast difference yeah I didn't
well oh I'm sorry Dr Chris oh I knew
that I I don't know you knew that it's
called the vasectomy because they Sni
the vast difference
yeah okay I mean okay I don't vast and
vas wow so just for VAs and vas I I
don't know I just think okay man obvious
I mean wow you know what a vast
difference is yeah what why we learned
about it in school okay man well you
also learned about a lot of other things
that you don't know anything about right
yeah yeah but but when it's about penis
IIs I pay attention Okay okay I believe
that anything penis related you were
very hey Chris long time fan of the show
Chris I'm coming to see in vanber um
reason why I'm calling in today is I was
in my car at a set of Lights uh the
first car before the crosswalk red light
I'm just looking this way and there's
this guy that's Crossing with a backpack
so I assume he goes to school which I'm
better than him I have a career he's
also walking and I have a car I'm better
than him anyways he's walking across the
road and he we make eye contact he looks
at me and he laughs and covers his laugh
and continues walking laughing and
looking back at me and guess if that's
been keeping me up in this oh
yeah nice nice nice am I insecure am I
an idiot for days after still wondering
what was he laughing at am I that funny
looking or is he the psycho for
presumably laughing at nothing with no
one
around thanks maybe he just a great
Wasing you know I this stuff happens to
me all the time and I always think oh
it's cuz they know who I am or something
like that like sure like the like like
yesterday I was walking into my car and
somebody uh I walked in front of
someone's car I was I was the guy in the
situation the other guy and they and
they were it was one of those I don't
know like weird vans that had like a
huge glass front and they let me go
which is always kind of annoying I think
it's it's like just go cars go I'll
figure it out yeah cuz they're being
nice you got be like thank you door open
from too far away yes exactly exactly
what it's like that's the worst so so as
I'm walking across they flick the lights
which I'm like I don't know it could
mean anything right cars coming watch
out it could mean go could mean High
could be hurry up could be anything and
I'm like oh and then I see I look
because she keeps doing it and she's
going like this and I'm like just a
train about to hit you you know yeah
yeah but I'm like like if it wasn't me I
would be like oh what's going on but
obviously I'm like oh she's a fan you
know and she was like and then she drove
by and said I love you and we got
married we so but um no but like that
kind of stuff happens to me all the time
time and I always default to oh they
know who I am they either like me or
hate me right like no matter what like
whatever happens I judge it in through
the lens of that sure being somebody
that doesn't isn't like in the I I no
public person that would drive me that
would I have a thing to be like oh it's
that if I didn't have that it would make
me go it would make me go crazy that
like yeah you'd have to be like okay I
have to let that go I don't think it
would bother me but I get it and I I
things like that I always chalk up to
just like people are so wired so
different and insane too yeah and it's
like who the hell knows what was going
on in that moment
like I I doubt even hearing the reason
would satisfy you in any way true and
also they I you know what I would do I
think is I would think oh they were
[__] with me that's what I would do
cuz I'm a little bit of a conspiracy
theorist yeah you are now I'm starting
to be I want to be more so to like
become more of one in your 40s you know
I want to become one more you're like
aspired to that hard yeah but you have
to really feel it I want to really
genuinely feel all of the conspiracies
and believe all of them why I bet it's
probably so stressful but honestly no
it's the opposite that's why they do it
that's why they believe it I free my
mind easy an just talk about freeing my
mind and stuff oh dude you got to do
your own research and free your mind
yeah those people much like they have it
figured out there's nothing I'm a very
very very extremely low
end uh I believe in like two two of them
and one of them is JFK and we know
that's actually I mean I think
inevitably because there are so many
there has to be least a handful that
that are not exactly correct but are
about things that are definitely fishy
and weird right JFK is not even a
conspiracy you know it it's more than
one guy okay what okay what do you think
yeah I don't know I've looked into it so
much I used to think for sure it was
more than one guy now I honestly I I
don't know
and it's so frustrating that we'll never
know like come
on come on just let it out let the
documents out but they can't though but
they can now [__] it yeah they can they
can dude what do they think the world's
going to like it's so stupid nobody even
really would do anything everyone who
had anything to do with it is dead now
anyway so long ago I know I know I know
yeah anyway anyway I it totally makes
sense you're not crazy you're not even
you're not it's not that you're insecure
that you remembering that no no I guess
it could be I mean if if yeah if you're
beating yourself up about it and be like
Oh am I ugly but like right yeah you
know you could be like oh why why is my
right side of my mustache running away
from my left side of my mustache you
could be like that I don't mean to make
you insecure but that is what's
happening is that have
any here in the middle of his thing oh
you're right d and that's okay the
mustache is running away from the middle
of his lip and itself his mustache is
going like this [__] [__] those nostrils
that's what they're doing yeah yeah it's
also saying [__] you to each side of the
mustache one side saying [__] you to the
other side so but I would say that uh
you're not insecure it seems like
honestly you're pretty secure you seem
like a cool dude you don't seem insecure
all let me tell you right now you're not
somebody that you look at and laugh at
no and and if you were I would know it
sure yeah but maybe you never know dude
it could be some like real weirdo who
sees a guy that looks like that and he's
like for like a totally absurd reason
when's last time you you have certainly
looked at someone and laughed because of
how they look right I mean I don't think
so I've done it recently really I I I I
laughed just like you catch a laughing I
don't think I've ever done that yeah it
made me do I they weren't even that
weird looking or dressed odd I just like
how funny that that person has a life
and like look at what they do you know
it was just I it must have been high I
don't I don't smoke weed but it must
have been high off life or something
high off life is what you were yeah
smoke weed every day we got another one
in the chamber hey Chris and Matt um
great you guys and I have been a baby a
really long time and then also I loved
your old podcast Matt and I'm really
excited about private record and also
next time I'm in La you better come to
my show what her show well anyways I had
a couple questions for both of you guys
and they kind of go hand in hand so I
thought I'd put them together okay my
first question is about so I was on a
date recently and um I got drunk on the
date and I ended up asking if I was
prettier than a celebrity and the
celebrity in in this case was Taylor
Swift and so my date paused for a minute
and then said no and then said why am I
comparing myself to celebrities and then
said that they weren't more than another
attractive guy Celebrity and so it was
kind of it was a kind of little tiny
argument um and then my second question
was so after that argument I decided to
continue to dig that hole and so I was
like okay well then what would you rate
me on a scale of 1 to 10 you really
asking for it and and then they gave
their answer and of course I didn't like
it yeah you're not going to cuz it
wasn't a 10 everybody wants a 10 right
um so I guess my question is um is it
normal
or totally a question I shouldn't ask or
anybody should ask to compare yourself
to a celebrity to somebody and then also
is it also another one of those
questions you shouldn't ask to ask
somebody to rate you on a scale of 1 to
10 with attractiveness what a great
question um would love to hear your
thoughts a great question with a
completely obvious answer though okay go
ahead I mean don't ask you're not the
answer is you don't ask if you
don't are if no here's what it is don't
ask if you're not prepared for answer
you don't like like if you're on a date
with someone I I would presume you
really want them to say 10 or yes you're
prettier than TW twiler
sift and so yeah
don't you're you're really asking for it
dude imagine you're on a date and you're
just like cutting thing so yeah am I
better looking than
yeah Kenneth
BR you know he has no
lips those too you know
um dude I
can't you know K BR has no lips what are
you talking about what are so simple Ken
BR has no lips how does a person have no
lips well I mean you know there's people
with NOP but he has lips you're you're
saying they're small they're they're on
the inside then I don't see them really
can we please pull up a picture of
Kenneth BR it's crazy it's like a
Simpson how could he have the career
that he has what do you mean directed
Thor he's a big Shakespeare actor for
his whole life yeah yeah you don't need
lips to do
Shakespeare he's got I would argue
straight up no
lips oh they're really thin look at that
is that weird they're like just like on
the isn't that weird bottom andp they're
like Muppet Muppet [__] like it just
closes look I'm Ken P you worse
impression yeah it's pretty crazy hey
man I never thought about that you never
did huh it Peaks a bit when he smiles
right like it's revealing a little bit
of pain mean does it no upper one zero
upper one upper one's gone bottom one
reveals a little bit even look at the
one look at look at him in the
[__] on the left no no no lower I
want that one I want that one look I
mean even that but again a little bit on
the bottom right that's a slit that is
that is not he has a slit those are not
lips that's so weird yeah the
Shakespeare one you
know anyway see the Shakespeare one
please yeah for sure see that one
there you go wow look at him there it's
awesome I'm going to dress I got to wear
that yeah we should dress look at that
outfit he's dressed like he got wrapped
in
curtains like he opened up the window
and had an accident accidentally um all
right so I mean even the [__] collar
um wild outfit huh yeah I don't like
first of
all why would you I don't know like
Taylor Swift that's such a weird one you
know like she's so famous but I would
presume that she came up yeah I I would
think so that's what I thought she was
like yeah look I I'm I'm sympathetic to
your cause but you can't be asking
questions like that if you don't want
the actual answer uh the problem is you
probably asked it and thought I am
prettier than and then when someone
disagrees which is obviously their right
you know uh then you're going to dislike
it even more than if the person just
said it appropo of nothing right um but
the the rap me of 10 thing is like the
most asking for it thing that that there
could even ever be yeah so that's a big
no
no to be like hey am I more handsome
than Kenneth Brana isn't that crazy I
guess guess out of 10 is crazy though is
what I'm saying yeah that's really
asking for it so you just you ask a
question so I'm a 10 out of 10 what do
you think I am because anything other
than that is wrong but go ahead would
never go on another date you know well I
I that's crazy to ask out on the first
date I think honestly yeah I thought she
said second date but still yeah we don't
whatever whatever it is we don't want
that we don't we don't want to ask
questions like that I mean I don't know
when when you say [__]
like like Christian is always
like like she'll be like that guy's so
hot on TV or something you know and I'm
like yeah or no right
mhm and sometimes I'm like that guy's
handsome right and she's like yeah like
last or to you as a guys yeah as guys uh
the dude who plays Negan on
um Jeffrey Dean Morgan yeah he's really
handsome he's handsome yeah
um uh I watch the postcard killings I
mean whoa wow oh okay conversation is
that movie is trash it sounds like I
don't even know what that is though it's
so bad and he's in it he's in a lot and
his daughter dies in the in in the movie
like before the movie starts like he's
the guy whose daughter dies and he's
smiling the whole movie it it it's so
weird he's just like wow looking for my
daughter and you're just like be sad wow
wow a choice you know he's he's handsome
yeah okay George cloney's handsome I
have a type those I was going to say
those guys are so similar uh but also
like I like other kinds of guys too you
know okay but who then who does Kristen
like she thinks we were talking about
how he's handsome the Jeffrey what was
his name Morgan have names not three but
yeah um so she thinks he's handsome she
thinks you know Jason MO is handsome
which to me he's big and handsome but
it's it's like what is he doing with his
everything so he's a bit much yeah he's
a bit much yeah um just visually there's
a lot going on you know yeah I don't
know who else is good-looking Christian
Bale's cool looking cool looking I would
say I think Michael fosin is real
handsome yeah he's yeah he's he's
handsome yeah she thinks he's really
handsome yeah but he's like [__] wafy
he's like like super thin yeah I don't
like that but I don't see I don't like
musly guys wow we're getting well they
don't have to be musly but he's he's
kind of musly in like a wiry way Michael
Fender yeah but like well I don't want
like a buff dude Vince Vaughn's hot oh
okay and he's not V now or back well
back down I don't know what it looks
like now yeah no one
does um yeah all right anyway yeah
anyways right okay
next what's up Chris and Matt I'm
listening to your guys' last week
episode and lady was just talking about
how she lost 70 lbs right and people are
saying she's skinny and all this stuff
and it made me think about the double
standard and what is appropriate to
respond with and typically when someone
says that they are usually not skinny or
bigger so when they say you're skinny
can you say you're fats or how does that
work uh I'm you know yaded and stacked
so it's all good but occasionally people
would be like oh you're looking skinny
and I want to say well you're looking
fat so yeah what do you guys say let me
know thanks I think should I stop me if
I've said this before but I remember I
was really young you were maybe 16 so I
was like 12 uh remember that dude Ken
yeah Ken kalahi yeah Ken kalahi I mean
wow what an amazing name uh well he
wasn't nice this day oh CU he said to
you you he's talking to you and he's you
guys are busting each other's balls he
said you got a you got a big nose and
you said yeah I remember yeah well you
got a big ass yeah and that was good cuz
he was a big dude he a big dude yeah so
the answer is and I still remember that
however many years later many many years
later uh and
I I think about that because a lot of
people my whole life have told me I'm
skinny and none of those people that
tell me that are skinny right no skinny
person ever like you're skinny they're
just saying it because they're the
opposite is skinny which is called fat
and they don't like
skinniness in their presence and even
though it's not really an insult to be
like you're skinny they make it one so
yes of course in that situation someone
in my situation can say well what do you
mean you're fat right what what are we
talking about here you know what I mean
uh but yeah it sucks all around it sucks
that you even get put in that position I
hate this [__] man I hate when people do
that kind of thing also that guy it
looks fit that's what he he addressed
that okay
yeah and you know I just it's that's
annoying when somebody says that it's so
annoying I mean who who also I mean we
talked about this when the girl called
in but like whoever is like you get
you're getting kind of fat no one ever
does that yeah and and and why is it
like what is going on that is so strange
that is culturally and socially okay to
be like you're too skinny and not okay
to be like oh you're getting a lot of
weight yeah you're fat [__] fat F fat
who fatty yeah um it's really weird
actually like the more you think about
it the weirder it is who dude you you're
getting
ugly you're looking bad when you get
older you keep looking worse and worse
could you
imagine I I saw someone the other day
they looked great I love when I see
someone that looks great that they look
better than they used to oh okay W bro
you look great yeah he really looked
great you know what he said to me what
no dude you look great oh he had to say
that no I you know what I mean I'm
kidding but no you're you're right
though there is that but the way he said
it made me believe that he was going to
say it anyway uh interesting yeah yeah
interesting and let's let's not I look
good let's not K ourselves okay well
cool yeah great great great great
everything's great hey guys so I was
staying in a hotel um in a different
town and I'm in North Dakota so it's
like8 de
um this particular day so I came down
from the hotel started my car went back
up I had my kids with me um we waited
probably like 20 30 minutes and we came
down to my car mhm as we're walking out
I realized that my car is not in the
spot that I parked it and I instantly
got like Panic you know my daughter's
like why' you move your car and then I
realize that my car is just parked in a
different spot so I'm like weirded out
like I don't even want to open my car
door like I have my kids is somebody in
there like what the heck's going on um
and as I'm like inching up to the door
this lady comes up to me and she's like
oh sorry about the confusion my battery
died and I needed to jump my car and
whatever um no not so I guess she just
moved my car to get like someone else's
car in there to jump it and I just
thought that was really ballsy and like
I get it no
appropriate I don't know I wouldn't have
done that I probably would would have
waited for the owner and also she in my
car already why wouldn't you just pull
the hood open and jump it with my car
like at that point you know no um I
don't know and obviously I was just like
oh okay like reliev that my car wasn't
stolen and like glad that nothing's
missing and whatever so I just like
played it off but it really kind of
bothered me yeah I don't know what would
you have done in that position no what
do you mean no just what they move the
car if they had to move the car a little
bit it's not a big deal it wasn't a
little bit well first of all I don't
agree that that's okay you can't just
move someone else's car also how did
they do that yeah if it no I think I
think what she was saying was it was
freezing so she went in to warm the car
up so the keys were in there I think
that's what she was saying and then she
went back to get her kids that's what I
thought oh but it doesn't matter I mean
that it doesn't the principle is still
the thing however I don't think that's
okay to do that actually I really really
really don't you can't if if if your car
is in the way and illegally parked it's
absolutely okay to do it okay but that
is that what that's not what I don't
know she she didn't she wasn't clear
about that she was just saying she
needed a
jump and so she moved her car so she
used it to jump the car right no no no
she didn't use her car oh wow I'm so
confused you're very confused she
actually said she didn't use my car she
should have and why did she move it at
all I don't we don't know unclear well
that's not good of her to do that part
that make that part it's not good to
make bar could but what I make up in my
head was that she had the car somewhere
the other person's car was near that
person was near hers and that other
person needed to get a jump so she had
to move that person's car and put
whoever was going to jump her car where
the other person where her car was to
get to jump cuz she didn't want to use
that's why she said why didn't you just
use my car to jump now things are
interesting and I am a detective for
knowing that yeah I mean that was good I
was deeply confused by the by her the
question but anyway that's I if somebody
moved my car look if somebody had a
McLaren I wouldn't do it but if it was
some Toyota or something I I would just
do it if it was a regular car that
anyone could drive I would just get in
and move it back a little bit and if
someone did it to my car I wouldn't mind
at all yeah you know what you swayed me
yeah I wouldn't mind I I unless it was
like a [__] high-end car then don't
do it I wouldn't do it here's here's
actually what I'll say I actually agree
with you now but when she was explaining
it I was imagining myself in that
situation and I knowing me and I think
obviously a lot of people her too
there's just something like that feels
it's like a violation of I guess stuff
your space it's your car and there's
some stranger in it like you didn't know
I guess so if someone called me up in my
room and was like can we move your I'd
be like oh yeah yeah go ahead I know I
understand so it's not about the simple
fact of someone else driving my car or
wanting to it's just like you don't ask
I don't know dude it just it would
bother me deeply if it happened to me
but as an objective Observer I've been
swayed by the case you it's not it's
just no it wouldn't bother me it really
wouldn't okay but I would add still
again it makes sense if you were angry
but yeah it's not the end of the there's
also a difference
between walking up like if I'm walking
up and somebody's in the way I go [__]
ah all right I'm just gonna move it I
guess you know what I'm saying then [__]
this I'm moving this [__] you know it's
a difference yeah yeah right because
it's like the L like oh I'm sorry I had
to I got to get jumped I got to go to
the thing I'm really sorry I didn't mean
to you know yeah it's not a big deal no
it's not a big deal if the person's like
yo I moved the car cuz you're in the way
and then it's like what the [__] are you
doing sure that's that all comes down to
but there's different people people
think that because you move the car a
certain because I don't know whatever
yeah no I think I think UL my friend hit
me with he sent a picture and he was
like dude am I being a get off my lawn
kind of old man or if I call the tow
truck company because there's somebody
kind of blocking my
driveway but I could still get in oh wow
dude don't do that that's what I said I
was like you get out and in who cares
yeah I said it's annoying and they're
parking illegally and it's on your
property but like write a note if you
think you know you're not going to catch
him in the act like just leave a little
note be like hey like yeah that's what I
told him tow them for a reason that
actually isn't impeding on anything I I
do think it's annoying when somebody
Parks like that though yeah of course I
agree the note is definitely worth doing
in that situation but getting some towed
yeah uh oh here we go but I kind of
finished it is it done or what yeah
pretty
much ttoo get all the way up I can't the
shirt's tight and it hurts say you're
talking about how buff you are
sore okay and and sometimes when you get
a tattoo I don't know if you know that
you got two I have two yeah um and you
don't have big ones right no they're pry
smaller right here um you feel sick
afterwards did you know that I did know
that about big ones no I didn't get sick
at all I have a buddy who got actually
just like that got a big huge like
beachcape whatever like it was the big
view of the beach he it was three
sessions I think he said Each one oh
really threw up during it oh wow I mean
no I mine doesn't so I I can't remember
which one I
did I felt like [__] afterwards
and I looked it up and I like oh it
happens but oh you didn't know you just
I I think I didn't know and I looked it
up but but last night I I finished this
and I felt fine and I went home and I
was like oh no I think I'm getting sick
this
sucks who was I around what did I and
then I and then I realized like an hour
later I'm like oh it's the tattoo thing
and I woke up this morning I felt great
but it's like it it really does make you
feel [__] sick dude like sick in your
stomach no no no like fever
oh I guess that makes sense you're being
poisoned when it gets in your body right
yeah dude I felt like I had a fever and
I didn't well or I had a little one from
that but like I mean I woke up feeling
fantastic but like dude it it it I I was
like oh no dude that's the worst feeling
it is in the beginning of when you know
it's coming it's the worst and you're
like can't it just be 3 days from now
the [__] worst it it it's worse it's
worse than being in bed knowing you're
sick yeah because the end is sooner the
worst part for me is the end is the
furthest no from now I I I agree but the
worst part about it
is when you know you're sick and you're
just going to spend the day in bed you
cancel everything you lay in bed and you
go all right let me watch TV let me get
comfortable sure it can kind of have a
fun element to it but the day before is
the worst because you still have to do
your [__] and you're like I think I'm
getting but am I but I'm still going to
go to this meeting they're not knowing
it that is the worst because and you
feel I would argue you feel worse even
though you truly feel worse when you're
full-blown sick you you feel it's it's
so much worse bro yeah I'm swaying your
mind a lot this podcast yeah I mean
you're making good cases I'm I'm an
openminded guy you it could be because
of the magic mind
magically swaying your mind delicious uh
all
right do another one hey Chris and Matt
I love you guys Chris ever since you
came to FSU in like 2018 I've been such
a huge fan um but I need advice on
communicating with little kids um I just
started my pediatric rotation I'm in
physical therapy school and I've never
been around kids before I don't have any
little cousins or anything like that
this is like my first time dealing with
kids and I cannot communicate with them
for [__] oh wow um I feel like I'm being
so fake and I'm like what's your
favorite color and they just they could
see the fakeness and I really want to
communicate well with them because their
therapy will be better if we have a real
connection and I felt like my motherly
instincts would kick in and they haven't
yet so Chris what's your advice you know
having two little boys did it come
naturally did you have to learn it um
yeah any advice is appreciated thank you
I think that you're thinking too much
about how they're kids I knew you were
going to say that yeah you know I mean
you don't have to be like hey bro but
like what's up bro what up you know but
like uh yo do you see contagion with
Matt Damon but like but like you
um uh but yeah you you got to you got to
have that in mind but like you're not
you can't be like don't baby them I mean
I don't know how old how old she's
dealing with with I guess all ages yeah
I guess so but um yeah also it might
have something to do with you it
probably has something to do with you
you know what I'm saying like like you
probably feel a certain way about it
because of the way either you are or
when you were a kid how people treated
you like
it's I don't know yeah I feel like I
mean you're probably way better at it
than you realize I would I would I mean
just hearing her is like she's great
yeah and it makes sense cuz you want to
be better at your job but the fact that
you don't have any experience with kidss
leads me to believe that your gauge of
whether you're doing a good job with
them is a little off yeah and obviously
it's going to take a minute for you to
to adjust but I Kids just like they're
they're not in my experience they're not
like that
complicated whatever you're doing and
your instincts tell you to do it
probably right also you have imposter
syndrome you know everyone has that like
they think like what am I doing am I
doing it right and I'm not really you
know that's true but you know who
doesn't have that me I don't have it who
doesn't have a imposter syndrome for
real you don't have it n I'm good really
I I should be doing the job I'm doing
that's not really what that is though I
know oh okay well I have imposter
syndrome you have no you just said
everyone know have a little you do have
it okay every yeah I think I think when
people actually don't have it that
they're probably not that like good at
what they do it's like the uh Dunning
Krueger thing yeah you it's like if you
think you're if you're the Dumber you
are the less you realize how Dum than
God I said I think I do have it before
you said what you said that's amazing
yeah well I knew you thought you yeah I
know you know so of course hey D hey
dude it's all good wow gonna fight me
it's all good and I have imposter
syndrome so I'm good at what I do but
yeah have you ever at any point been
like I don't know how to how to connect
with not connect with but to get through
to I mean obviously not Billy
but
um No NO phase of his I was going to say
career NO phase of his career as a child
so far not yet no yeah yeah that's
amazing with Billy it was a little
different though I mean he you know he's
10 months but like yeah but like with
with Billy it's a little different
because
it's Calvin it it's weird when you have
two kids one kid the first kid by
besides the fact
that you're in love with this with this
boy or or girl you created whatever it
is
um you your whole life is completely
changed
mhm I turned my head my head just hurt
again because I hit the I hit the shelf
on the [__] and yeah so that's twice
one day so but but
you the SEC when the second one comes
it's not a whole life change sure so
it's it's I went not anymore but in the
beginning I was like oh is
everything am I still good at being a
dad am I still because it didn't line up
it's not rocking my world like it did
and and does that mean anything but it's
just
because yeah it's more of it it's not a
difference it's just more and and so and
now now I feel completely and utterly uh
okay about it because it it's Billy is
his own person and it's its own its own
separate thing you know but yeah in that
way it was weird for me uh connecting
but no not not now yeah but Billy's also
the happiest baby in the world it's
really funny yeah stop smiling I mean
I've been around plenty of babies and
stuff but like this boy is just I mean
he never stops smiling yeah he doesn't
stop smiling it's so hilarious you they
get that from me no he does and Calvin
is happy kid but he was always like this
yeah he's a bit more of a serious I mean
dude Billy is just it's we call I I say
he's got a deadlift smile because it
goes from nothing to like completely
lift it up yeah yeah yeah yeah anyway
it's hilarious yeah he's a funny yeah
all
right hi Chris and Matt I a new viewer
Watcher of your podcast listener and I
am really impressed welcome by the way I
love you I have a question for you I'm
from Nebraska oh wow and I'm at a pizza
restaurant with my boyfriend wow and at
the end of our meal we had the pizza and
I'm boxing it up and the waitress comes
with our
Bill and those little Andes mints the
green I know I haven't thought about
them in a while these I hate I have the
rapper uhhuh because my boyfriend ate
all of them he didn't leave any for me
he's being how do I handle this you
should thank thank you for being truly
you do I ignore it or do I address it
thank you for being truly you and front
of me you're comfortable as I am a
little perur no thank you love your show
keep up the good work wanted an Andy's
mint chocolate thing yeah I know you
felt comfortable enough in front of her
to take it them all that's not what
feeling comfortable to take them all for
himself cuz he wanted them no that's
being a selfish [__] dude that's not
that's not like gifting her like than
you you get the Trum me that's that's
such a shitty way of looking at it wow
dude she's has so done it has so taken
the last thing or whatever and
christen's just like why did you do that
and you're like you have to be
appreciative because I'm sh who I am
that's the most [__] thing ever dude
this is the true me hey dude you eat one
you go like this and she's there and
she's not eating you go like
this you get to see the
TR that's you're welcome for the try
dude that is like textbook [__] you
know yeah but um obviously bring it up
and not in a thankful way bring up be
like hey did you consider that I might
want one too and see what he says of
course I did and then what did you
do the biggest IED you the [__]
[__] could you imagine the being on a
first date
and don't you want to get to know me
yeah I don't understand what the problem
is I GI to do the Trum me you're up
bowling go everybody says their most
this this would be good everybody says
the most important thing especially
women always say the most important
thing is communication being open and
honest well here I am this is me yeah
now are you going you going to finish
that or what you pull their pasta over
and all of my glory hey take out of her
hand while she's eating it it all my
glory her sandwich taking them money out
of her wallet to here's here's
another here I'm going to go beyond that
because what we do is in this podcast we
peel beyond the the we peel the layers
of the onions we you're already in a
terrible zone so you're going even more
terrible yes okay we we push past the we
we move the curtain we look not just at
the front yard completely into the
neighbor's house right okay yeah
so don't
this is something that is just nuts to
me you eat a meal and they bring you a
[__] piece of [__] candy
afterwards dude I I didn't say I wanted
that I didn't order it what the [__] are
you doing it's such a ah here you go
thing I'm not a dog dude I ordered what
I wanted I paid for I wanted why are you
giving me a [__] [__] Candy by the
way that nobody really wants andies are
actually a step up from what it usually
is honestly it's usually the shitty
circular peppermint thing even worse
with the pink in the middle those are
the worst on god dude who ever liked one
of those but here's the thing at least
that makes a little sense what did I
just cuz it's a mint yes so like you ate
here's a mint but it's candy but okay
yeah but the chocolate has mint in it
too but still it's just like I'll get
that if I want that it it you might as
well just hand me a [__] blow dryer I
don't need that a chicken wing yeah yeah
yeah just like a ROM piece here's more
food you're full here's more here I have
a chicken wing and and they just put it
on the [__] check too they put it on
the check it's like don't give me candy
just for no reason God that I've never
even thought about this this is really
really weird it's been happening since I
I was a kid no I'm always like dude
here's another one uh airplane and they
here's a a wet nap for you for no
[__] reason I'm sitting in if you're
in you're sitting in the plane here's a
here's a moist towet for Fu why do they
do that on planes do they still do that
by the way for what dude I go like this
I don't want one thank you every every
person ever next to me goes like this
ooh what you want wet hands for [__]
what you know what it is actually people
beinged like free [__] yep it doesn't
matter what it is dude it's so and also
dude that sucks too yeah and then this
big of a square yeah can't find the wa
is this the wet nap now it's the wet nap
that big it's this big dude and you just
like this yeah yeah yeah for sure there
soap on your hands or whatever the soap
on the hands the residual soap on the
hands is terrible dude start the
movement no thank you I don't want that
wet nap I did it I took it the other day
because I had stick I actually had
sticky hands I was like wow this is the
first time it ever came in handy see
okay yeah yeah well I think that also
with the candy to take this to make this
uniform also do with the candy take the
candy go back into the kitchen MH and
hand them to the chefs at the restaurant
I didn't order this I don't want this
take it back how much is this did you
charge me for this right yeah this is
this better not be on my bill it's just
three little shitty peppermints uh I
have eaten them though that's that's the
other thing that sucks is like sometimes
you'll just eat them there those
candies taste like [__] I thought you
said you like them the the peppermint
ones oh
again that's a little bit peppermints
are those are the worst man they're not
it's not just mints and when they when
you're done with them your mouth has
like seven layers of sugar on inside it
disgusting and guess what you totally
forget the good meal you just had
because you got this [__] film layer
upon layer of [__] [__] ass
peppermint in your mouth so disgusting
it's [__] gross it's whoever made
that [__] that's like stop doing that
everybody so rich whoever made
peppermint you know like that and and
and like just for I mean they're dead
they're long and dead now how they get
yeah how did they get to be so lucky
that's the thing dude it's just it's
it's a waste of space it's a waste of
[__] space Here's a little peppermint
ball that [__] sucks it's a circular
disc you're going to put it in your
mouth it's basically plastic and I'm
going to cover your mouth with film and
you're not going to remember the really
nice enchiladas you just had uhhuh
you're not going to remember at all the
really good meal you just had and guess
what in 20 minutes it's going to taste
worse y yep in your [__] mouth and
you're going to have a sip of water and
be like w this water tastes like [__]
shitty disgusting sugary peppermint so
here's the movement if you have a
restaurant and you hand out stuff hand
out little pieces of dog [__] yeah same
thing it is the same thing how how you
give me this or your own [__] because it
dogs hard to collect why' you give me
this oh well it's better than peppermint
it's the same thing I'm giving you
something you didn't ask you know how
restaurants usually give you little
peppermints okay well those are really
terrible and so is this really terrible
so there's really no difference so here
you go anyway I'm giving you my but my
what comes from my butt yeah hope you
enjoyed your your time here at Denny's
um yeah so anyway is there another
one oh the [__] the way [__] the way he
did it hi guys this is Shannon hey um I
called him before with the private
dinner party question oh yeah and was
rightfully roasted for my monologue and
very thin Christmas tree but we loved it
oh yeah yeah we did we did love
it making me laugh and keeping me honest
very cool you're sweet um as you might
be able to tell I am near nearly 8
months pregnant awesome I was going to
say something and I thought wait but you
never say something you should my
husband and I's first baby girl and
we're very excited eight months quick
shout out to my husband Brian who is
away at C for work we have about six
weeks until he can come home and we have
this baby yeah um so on the kind of
theme of having children in
childhood my new question for the two of
you is what is your earliest childhood
memory oh dude I don't remember mind
thanks so much love you guys good
question I I before we even get into
it there are so many stories I've heard
about me that I don't know if I remember
it or if I just know the story we' we
haven't talked about this exactly but
we've talked about versions of this how
other people's stories certainly other
people's stories about I agree me as a
kid yeah I think over the years I've
heard them enough where I'm like this
happened to me and I remember what I can
remember is the day we brought you home
really yeah wow I remember I remember
two things about that day I remember
your life was from that point on much
worse and two no I I I remember your
fingers were wrinkly and I was in the
back seat while you were in the car seat
and I asked Mom I said why are his
fingers all wrinkly and he said
sometimes babies have wrinkly fingers
when they're born and stuff and then
later on that day or I guess it could
have actually been the next day but but
Grandpa bam was over and everyone and
they got me uh a he-man toy and um I I
opened it up and I and I saw the toy and
I said thanks you only got me this cuz
he's here now whoa dude Mom and Dad
should have known if they didn't already
know that you were trouble from that
[__] day forward W but I was just too
I was too smart at 3 and a half at three
and a half is crazy to that is nuts it's
like Cal saying that I couldn't imagine
that I guess I could no Cal would yeah
he might say that yeah so yeah kids are
smart bro you get a taste of your own
medicine yeah I know I know and every
time he does some [__] like that I go
like yeah okay yeah you deserve I get it
I do deserve it uh my earliest memory
was how old were you when you were in
first grade like how old is a kid in I
don't know how old is somebody in first
grade do we know uh like six seven yeah
maybe okay so then I was three or four
okay yeah that's run mine same sure yeah
and uh remember Miss Antoine of course
first grade right I'm right about that I
had her in kindergarten I think oh then
I thought I was younger okay then that
makes I had Miss Harlem for first first
grade okay then it was Kindergarten when
you were in kindergarten so I was you
were like five I was two okay so really
young yeah yeah this I I remember being
really young cuz Mom was holding me
right okay this is a this is a crazy
memory okay we went mom was going to
talk to Miss Antoine like it wasn't like
you were in trouble it was like a parent
teacher I was with her cuz I wasn't in
school yet and she was carrying me and
it was Miss Antoine remember her
assistant what was her name I don't
remember this was like Mont M Mont Fury
or something like that yeah yeah I do
nice woman yeah I don't remember what
she look like but I remember the name
yeah whatever that sounds like that they
was the two of them yeah
and Miss antoan was called her Miss
monor because it's something like that
miss antoan and miss mon were making
such a big deal out of me and I was so
small yeah and miss miss Antoine
honestly just I had her later too so I
knew as well just straight up the nicest
woman on the planet she like I even
remember just the warmth she's sweetest
she was great yeah uh and she was making
the biggest deal out of me but because
she was old she had a very like old like
puffy wrinkly very face and and she was
coming up to me and so demonstrative and
so like yeah sweetly and making be and
she get closer and closer and I just
thought okay these are those things in
that book that I have the Dinosaur
book if if I stay
still oh my [__] it won't get me well
you definitely remember that that wasn't
a story that was told to you because you
that's a thought you had no I remember
all of this extremely well I was
terrified but I I also somehow knew I
was safe cuz Mom was being so reciprocal
of her sweetness so I was just like I
was like if I just stay still if I just
stay still if I just say so and I
remember she got like so close to me
like she was like oh and she was just
like this and I was just like such a
[__] idiot you know uhoh she's one of
those things in the book I was dinosaurs
yeah yeah like a T-Rex there was like a
scene from Jurassic Park for real when
dinosaurs oh such a nice lady oh such a
nice lady uhoh she's actually a dinosaur
the biggest idiot that's ever been on
tripping so hard on acid I remember that
was that day I gave you acid yeah that's
that was what did it yeah isn't that
funny though dude yeah it is weird that
you remember that this is why they
say that your [__] book was written
before you were like four yeah right
yeah totally yeah it's just like well
they say two to five right that's the
zone you really get shaped almost like
entirely I guess so but I mean like
there's really a lot of evidence where
you know if you're if you were in foster
care the first year of your life it's
hard for you because you didn't have
just the first year yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean that makes so much sense so many
like minor but hugely important
developmental stages there my therapist
was telling me
that
she was like she gave an example like
you know when like you're because it was
we she talked about this when I had Cal
first and I was like you have to be
attuned to what your baby needs and you
know how sometimes you want to go like
hey look at me and then they try to look
away and like you're like no over here
you know what I me like that that's
technically in a very small way little
trauma because you're like the baby's
like I don't want to be doing that but
you know what I mean and that changes
that make that develops you I know I
know it's crazy is so hard well that's
why when when you go to like I know it
is hard and like you that's the kind of
thing where it's like you're not giving
your kid what you need but it's not your
fault what they need yeah yeah but what
they need but it's not your fault of
course so it's like Mom and Dad have as
every mom and dad has [__] up but you
to to to realize that this is a huge
thing I learned in rehab but like to
realize
that because your your my knee-jerk
reaction is to be like no they were
great no no they didn't [__] up no
that's not their fault and it's not
their fault but no that's the key it's
not right it's not their fault but they
did mess up and just as I'm going to
mess up well no parent ever has ever not
messed up over like thousands of times
right but in my rehab I one of the main
things was people were like no I don't
want to blame my parents for that like
you know and it was like you don't have
to blame them for that but that is why
happened and it's okay and and you can
have space for both feelings you know
what I mean didn't mean to get so deep
but didn't mean to get so deep
but but wow look at your muscles man
that's if you want to go over listen to
the all the lifeline luxuries go over
there Lifeline luxury it's patreon.com
Lifeline luxury and uh we keep moving up
you know but the lifeline luxury is
fantastic uh and then uh all my new tour
dates are on sale Chris lea.com I'll be
in Sagen and I'll be in uh North
Charleston South Carolina and a bunch of
different places I got Vancouver coming
up soon that first show sold out second
show selling out so go get those tickets
and Colona I'll see all thousands of you
soon and you want to make sure you
subscribe to the private record channel
on YouTube uh episode three coming out
this week it is crazy you got a couple
episodes out now peep the last one it's
super wild uh and yeah what else oh yeah
you wanted 10 one1 with me Matt deia go
to mat.com advice session just for you
and me uh and the merch Lifeline
merch.com don't forget to get the merch
we love
you
hello
[Music]
hello hello